what was that place called chefs
chef's voyage or something chef's voyage
and it was a real [ __ ] hole and i was uh
well it was nice they had real nice
silverware
i mean the kind of silverware you looked
at and you were like damn did this
you know am i on the titanic
but you were just in a shopping mall you
were over there by payless shoes really
so if you looked out the window you
would know you weren't on the titanic
but if the windows were closed and you
were just staring at the silverware
you could maybe have the idea you were
boating but anyway
i worked up there and my buddy worked up
there and he was homoerotic
you know he preferred the company of men
and and men's bodies
but anyway he was about 40 or something
and he was a you know
he was also a real he was a boxer he was
like a real you know
kind of this little italian he looked
kind of
you know he looked like a little he
looked like a kind of a senior citizen
but also like a child
at the same time he was that kind of
mixed italian daddy
you know that mozzarella mad man
and his name was billy conforto rest in
peace because he ate a bunch of pills
years later
and he drove a car into a um embankment
out there in laplace louisiana
and he was uh he was a good friend of
mine
and we got stoned one time during when
princess diana died
and i didn't know what princess diana
was you know i thought it was
you know a beanie baby or like a nice
dessert
and we'd gone over to his house because
he was my friend
you know we were actually really good
friends and we were close friends and
and i miss him and he uh
and he would
he had made us a couple chicken cutlets
you know
grilled us up a couple of you know
hearty chicken breasts
i mean a real chicken not one of these
weak [ __ ] that they're pumping all
these vitamins and
and riboflavins into over there and
you know out there in laurel mississippi
but i'm talking about them real bad boys
i'm talking about the kind of chicken
that gets up in the morning and does
some
you know does some lunges and does some
uh
you know work does uh um you know
maybe 40 pounds of incline press
i'm talking about that kind of chicken
that reel that the [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
that'll sing
you know what i'm saying i'm talking
about maybe a black chicken you know
kind of lady that'll be singing in the
you know singing in a chorus in a yard
while the other chicken's just doing
some [ __ ] i'm talking about a real
bad [ __ ]
and he had some of those cutlets those
high-end cutlets
and he grilled those headers up and we
had gotten stoned
doing drugs you know doing uh
marijuana and we got so stoned man and
we um
and that's when princess diana died and
he kept telling me
and i don't know what the [ __ ] he was
talking about dude i thought he was
talking about a damn beanie baby and i
was [ __ ] up
but anyhow he and i worked together at a
place and they caught me one time in
about in a
freezer section in the freezer you know
they had bread pudding in the freezer
and i'd sneak back there
and do a couple whippets and had me a
couple of [ __ ] quick handfuls of
bread pudding
and if you've ever worked at a
restaurant you know what i'm talking
about it's called taking a break
and that was something we would do and
i'd get back there and hit them whippets
get me four [ __ ]
you know and get get feeling all kind of
creamy up in my skull
and then i fill my mouth with that just
god damn i don't know if you've ever had
a little bit of bread pudding
and eating it out of your own hand but
that is the damn lord's tartar right
there boy
yeah dang some people when they die you
know they want to be
embalmed or they want to you know you
know they want their family to shoot him
out of a
cannon or something into a damn you know
into a damn you know school yard or they
want to be
you know putting uh in one of them
what are those lava lamps but
this was uh what i'm talking about is
when you die [ __ ] what am i talking
about
oh i'm talking about that bread pudding
i'm talking about this the kind of [ __ ]
when i die
i want to be embalmed with that bread
pudding
and pour a little bit of that [ __ ]
raisin sauce on my body
that bourbon just that bourbon backwash
just dip daddy's ass in that bourbon
backwash and you put me in a casket like
that
you're gonna see how many people come to
my funeral
that's what i'm saying it's a damn this
funeral is five star
this is a michelin five star funeral
baby
and god damn what's that boy on is he
was he
he smells good he smells like he's got
that rum raisin sauce on him
and that's how i want to die i want to
be embalmed with bread pudding like a
real man
like a real man but billy conforto was
one of the first real men that i ever
met in my life and he was
you know he was good to me he was
protective of me
and he you know when other kids would do
me wrong he would fight them
and i guess in hindsight it's a little
weird to think a 35 year old man was
fighting children but
you know where i grew up that was what
it was what it was you know i'm saying
age didn't really matter you would just
fight each other
you know you see a six-year-old and a
[ __ ] 82 year old out there just
you know out there beating each other in
the neck with
you know kind of small pieces of wood
lean pieces of wood
swa swaths good evening good afternoon
and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one